i want to say thank you so much for
having me back
[Applause]
justin bieber returns to the stage on
his justice tour nearly two months after
he was diagnosed with the rare facial
paralysis syndrome that left half his
face frozen obviously
as you can probably see from my face
um
i have uh
this syndrome called uh
ramsey hunt syndrome
the pop star was in great spirits sunday
night in italy to resume his tour he
kicks things off backstage with high
energy before stepping out to perform
[Music]
a spirit of gratitude is felt all around
as the purpose singer and his wife haley
bieber joined his concert crew for a
prayer circle we thank you for the
people here in italy and this
opportunity just to bring a message of
love
to these folks i pray god he will give
us the strength
give us the clarity of thought we thank
you god for justin in this moment that
he has to to share his his message of
hope and love
[Music]
during the show justin performed his hit
song holy and haley posted a
behind-the-scenes clip on instagram
cheering on her man quote one thing i
know for certain is you can't keep this
guy down i think it's just my job to be
a light it only makes sense that
justin's return is centered around
prayer and positivity since the pop star
leaned on his faith throughout his scary
diagnosis i have hope and um i trust god
and um i trust that this is all gonna
it's all for a reason and despite
needing to postpone the tour after the
health scare his fans in italy gave the
biebs a warm welcome back
in celebration of his good health and
return to the stage justin thanked his
believers for their love and support we
are here to be the difference makers and
i want to say thank you to each and
every one of you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you